the federal reserve has lost control
what am i talking about yesterday they
went ahead they increased interest rates
by another 50 basis points this follows
the last interest rate hike of 25 basis
points if we go back to march of 2020
the federal reserve and elected
officials they saw the liquidity price
unfolding due to the pandemic and the
government mandated lockdowns asset
prices were selling off stocks were down
25
gold down 15 and bitcoin down 50 percent
in a single day the fed and elected
officials they stepped in with monetary
and fiscal stimulus they wanted to push
asset prices back up they wanted to
mitigate short-term pain but mitigating
that short-term pain ended up coming at
a cost that cost was long-term pain and
that long-term pain showed up in the
form of inflation we now have 8.5
inflation the highest in 40 years within
the united states and of course the
federal reserve is being pressured into
acting and so what they've done is
they've gone ahead and tapered asset
purchases and they've started to raise
interest rates now two rate hikes the
first one 25 basis points and the second
one 50 basis points the problem with
doing this is that while they're hiking
interest rates there's an economic
contraction going on we got the q1 gdp
data and it showed up as an annualized
negative 1.4 percent and so there's a
big big problem brewing on the horizon
the federal reserve is hiking interest
rates they're tightening monetary policy
at the exact same time that the economy
is contracting this is not good but they
have to make a decision are they going
to address 8.5 inflation and potentially
push us into a recession or are they
going to try to avoid the recession and
just have people live with the high
inflation it's really a lose-lose
situation the federal reserve has lost
control and then to make the situation
more complex we're going into midterm
elections at the end of this year
politicians on both sides of the aisle
they don't want high inflation and they
definitely don't want a recession the
federal reserve can't be right and so
ultimately what we saw yesterday was
exactly what the market expected a 50
basis point hike but the market's also
pricing in anywhere between 2.75
and 3 interest rates by the end of the
year it's a lot of hiking the federal
reserve would have to do i don't think
that they're ever going to get close to
that in fact what i think is going to
happen is that the fed is going to
continue to hike rates and they're going
to be too aggressive and move too
quickly we're gonna get pushed towards a
recession and maybe even enter one and
all of a sudden the fed's gonna have to
chill out they're gonna have to stop
hiking interest rates and potentially
even cut interest rates to go ahead and
start stimulating the economy again
there's no way politicians will go into
an election season with high inflation
and a recession they will pressure the
federal reserve to make sure that
people's portfolios are going up and the
cost of goods are going down the federal
reserve has lost control it's chaos out
there there's complete uncertainty and i
don't envy their position they're
well-intentioned they're doing the best
they can but it's a lose-lose situation
if the fed doesn't hike we get high
inflation if the fed hikes we get a
recession and actually we're in the
double whammy of we've got both right
now this isn't good you at home all you
need to do is make sure you're educated
stay alert and start putting your
portfolio in a position where over a
long period of time it'll benefit from
betting on the united states economy and
innovation problem solving and
entrepreneurship because i think that's
the only solution that anyone has
available right now hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time